and China's got super soldier programs
yeah wait what yeah you didn't know that
oh of course they do no yeah let me let
me search that one classic China they
just do whatever like whatever sci-fi
thing they saw from the 80s like the
China's just gonna try it look at this
story like that China has done human
testing to create biologically enhanced
super soldiers says top Us official U.S
intelligence agents didn't immediately
respond to requests about whether China
seeks to create soldiers like those in
Captain America but doesn't this make
sense don't they like specifically ask
certain like athletic people to have
children to like create more athletic
people like this makes complete sense
that they would be like if it applies to
their sports but wouldn't apply to their
military what if they made
what if they genetically engineered
humans to be
to like have superpowers jump really
high or you know throw lightning bolts
or something would you be really that
opposed to it if they made the X-Men
then we don't think it's really cool
like they'd be like Harry Potter and all
the Millennials would be very very into
it
possibly yeah yeah or there's gonna be
like these like Chinese shills like
super Red Army whatever whatever yeah
I'll be X-Men but it'll be very CCP
X-Men you know that's a cool idea for uh
for for a fiction sci-fi kind of thing
though China invents super soldier serum
that gives people some kind of abilities
I would if I were to do it it wouldn't
be super like ridiculous like laser eyes
that's nuts but it would be like
stronger faster jump higher be younger
things like well that was just trt dude
and then what happens is people in the
United States start justifying why the
Chinese Communist party is good
desperately begging for access to their
serum technology
you coined that that's copyrighted for
Tim Caster yeah you're already here
first they'll be able to see super far
like long distance Vision there will be
like spies working within the U.S that
are just like American citizens who turn
traitor for China because they want
access to this technological advancement
what's our super soldier program like
you you know we got one we better no we
don't I no way you've seen our military
recruiting strategies we're like look at
this girl she's got two moms hold their
breath they're like you need dudes that
can hold their breath for like 60
minutes yeah I was thinking about the
fish man they can there's these things
where they can inject into I'm not sure
what it is exactly some some sort of red
blood cell or uh something this is an
old Tech too like from 15 years ago into
the bloodstream and it lets you like
only breathe once every
30 minutes or something I should find
this there's those divers I think that
might be some there's those diversity
for like yeah 10 whatever they can be
like down there for like 10 minutes or
something crazy like that really low
deaths yeah yeah you mean like just like
General deep diving but that's because
of like like your has to do with like
the compression of gases it has to do
with like everything's slowing down for
you there's a whole lot of stuff that
goes into it like because you're going
that like that deep in the water I don't
again I don't know a lot about this but
I've read into in the past in the past
as well so we're getting real
transhumanists in here yeah we are
that's the name of the day dude did you
find it no I I know that logging this on
mines like in 2012. they've done uh they
do those those Guinness World Record
holding your breath thing yeah and it's
like I don't know six minutes or
something but then they also do
oxygenated holding your breath where you
breathe pure oxygen and like
hyperventilate and then hold your breath
you can hold your breath like 20 or 30
minutes or something ridiculous you guys
seen the steroid Olympics no no they're
talking no there's a guy I think it's an
Indian guy who's trying to start like a
steroid a limp like where you can like
steroids and you like compete oh my gosh
we're watching that over there no more
Olympics watch 24 minutes holding his
breath underwater what wow yeah also
like how do you occupy your mind during
that time I can't even smoke a cigarette
as well that's what I mean though like
when you are running out of oxygen
you've just trained yourself to stay
totally calm so you don't panic and use
more oxygen yeah you don't feel you're
suffering at auction you just feel how
CO2 build up that's what you get like
either one though it's going to also be
hard to keep your mind there's
technically oxygen in the water so if
you're and there's oxygen in the air you
can take in through your skin I know
it's a little transhumanist to think
that you can get it any other way but I
think you can you can drink water and
get oxygen that way so yeah there are
other ways yeah
man I wish I had this this crazy article
that I read 15 years ago about they were
like injecting stuff into people and
they didn't have to breathe the guy
who's got the 25 minute record was
pre-breathing 100 oxygen prior to
holding the holding his breath
so it's kind of like the steroids thing
oh that's crazy so you can use Huff
oxygen and then you can just breathe the
world for longer the world record for
non-oxygen assisted breath hold is 11
minutes and 35 seconds by Stefan for
women it's nine minutes so when is that
gonna be the thing like when they're
selling air because of the air quality
is going to hell because of uh you know
Canada's blowing all the smoke down here
we're gonna start just helping oxygen to
survive is that gonna be the next big uh
like big business they sell those Like
Oxygen cans right intravenous oxygen
injection for patients who cannot
breathe yeah I think this is it this is
from 2012. an injection that delivers
oxygen directly into the bloodstream for
patients who cannot breathe so it's if
someone like goes into cardiac arrest
you you can you can get it right into
the blood so you don't need to breathe
to get your oxygen I'm not a
transhumanist guy but that sounds pretty
sweet the fact that like we're basically
just machines that you can just dump
like a little bit of like oxygen into
your bloodstream like this and you don't
have to breathe that's crazy like wow
dude like super steady that's what I
think all the time injections sounds so
fun but like tiny gas-filled
microparticles can be administered
directly into the bloodstream supplying
it with oxygen
but they're made of a single layer of
fatty molecules that's around a
minuscule pocket of oxygen that are
placed in a liquid solution and injected
into the patients is that from 2012 also
the zolt attack I wonder what they got
now but it's this crisper stuff I wonder
if people will even need to breathe very
much I I think China has probably
genetically engineered a whole
generation of soldiers that we don't
even just underwater people that can
live underwater stuff to their kids in
hospitals already I assume that like
they already like have like a cocktail
that they're feeding in there I don't
know if they care about the average
person the average person can live their
life fund the economy do menial labor
and then they start creating genetically
engineered super soldiers for higher
level stuff but we all know how that
goes because we've all seen The Wrath of
Khan right yeah unfortunately no no I
haven't what happens so the long story
short of it in Star Trek a part of the
lore in the past is that humans started
genetically engineering people and then
created super strong people who
eventually felt like they were better
than everyone else and should be in
charge because there's no smarter faster
and stronger and then I I think the
story has been a long time since the
movie I think they get Frozen and
launched into space to get rid of them
and then uh the crew of the Enterprise
discovers the vessel and then unfreezes
them that was basically that might be
um Into Darkness with the Benedict
Cumberbatch I'm not sure if it was it
was a similar plot for Wrath of Khan but
I think that was right I just haven't
seen Wrath of Khan's as a little kid I
just love the future where we when we
have a problem we just freeze it and
launch it into space dude we're like see
you later I can't deal with you anymore
people are still are actually like
really doing that right now too they're
like really looking into some guy
dropped out of high school or something
the Free Press Barry White's paper did
an article on it some guy dropped out of
high school to start freezing people
he's like freezing dogs now but he has
other people signed up that are like
gonna be frozen for long term wasn't
that the rumor for like Walt Disney when
I was
that happened to Walt Disney
I feel like a lot of stuff could have
happened is it working are they bringing
them freezing into them I don't know if
they're bringing them back I know that I
think they're freezing them now with
like the intention of bringing them back
eventually would you do that if you
could
dude we need something wrong would be
you'd come up and your brain would be
half melted like right you think
oh yeah I think it would never work but
the main issue is that freezing causes
water water to crystallize so if you
freeze a person it destroys and ruptures
the cell wall so they need to find ways
to super cool and slow down the chemical
process in the body without causing the
destruction
go through like what spin you really
fast
so that there's constant shake you just
shake you violently because then it the
water can't freeze do you think people
ever ask to just be kept permanently in
a coma they'll be like I'm towards the
other life but I don't like this decade
just keep me in a coma for 10 years and
that will be like a voluntary state that
seems much more like a real thing than
like the freeze skip a decade I feel
like that's what people will end up
doing if I I don't have a sign father
trust I trust him on this it would be
damaging to freeze and unfreeze The
Chronic chronogenic technology is
different somehow it's they're seeking
to bypass that or whatever so but I feel
like that's what people will opt for in
the interim they'll be like well I'll
just go on pause for a couple years do
it they're gonna be like if you're 13
and above you're allowed to you can stay
there for about 10 years then you can be
you know 23 instantly
like that's crazy
um yeah that would that I mean with a
neural so I'm derailing this
conversation I'm thinking about super
soldiers I just keep thinking about we
need a super soldier program we better
have one because we would be prepared
there's no way we have a super soldier
program or at least not with the current
federal government I'm sorry I just
don't believe it we have such low
military recruitment rates we'll con
that's exactly why we would have the
problem we lower the fitness standard so
we can't even get soldiers into this
because there's no way you know so you
you are you are thinking this is about
them I would like to recruit you to come
here and get injected no they're taking
babies 20 years ago injecting women in
in the womb and then giving birth to das
like docile but aggressive what I mean
by that is I should say submissive and
easily commanded six foot five super
ripped naturally like we do it to cows
right like the US military is willing to
drop nuclear bombs all over the planet
blowing stuff up I would be surprised if
they were not willing to genetically
engineer babies 30 years ago I would
grant you that except for the fact that
our military constantly changes
leadership everywhere so let's think
about like space force right Trump is
like let's bring it back and the Biden
was like no but what what but why the
Assumption like why the assumption that
the military is disclosing to the public
everything they're doing
public but I don't think every Federal
Administration would keep the program
going and there's no way it could grow
faster they lose so much money like
they've like lost like there's so much
money that's not accounted for like
there's I I would not put anything on
the audit yeah like I I don't understand
how so many people think if I haven't
heard it in the news the military
doesn't have it it's not that I don't
think we've had it in news I don't think
that our federal government takes our
military seriously enough to have that
kind of force that I just don't trust
them bro they do it would be cool but I
don't think if you haven't heard the
military doing it you assume they're
doing nothing this actually is an
argument for the inverse if the military
seems to be doing nothing it's probably
because they're bolstering in some other
way right the military-industrial
complex is not going to just drop their
arms and be like I guess we can't do
anything anymore more and they're not
going to come out and be like we
invented this new kind of bomb if that
is their premium top tier weapon that
makes no sense what makes more sense is
the military National complex wants more
and more money for tons of stuff they've
been doing biological research with gain
of function research and we only just
figured that out banned it they brought
it back so in in my view we know for a
fact China well I should say it's been
reported by using intelligence officials
that China has a super soldier program
I'd be willing to bet the US the US
military has crazy weapons you could not
even think of the idea that imagine if
when we were working on the Manhattan
Project the US government immediately
came out went to the president said we
are currently working on the nuclear
bomb here's how it works and what it
does it will be commissioned in this way
and located in in it'll be located in
these areas that's insane nobody knew
what they were building it was all
speculation and then was it Truman right
he was like let's blow up Japan to prove
to the world the power that we have and
all only then people went holy crap and
the funny thing is when it happened news
took a while to travel these days news
travels fast I'm I'm willing to bet what
makes the most sense is that the US has
been working on insane military attack
that you don't know about and won't know
about until they need to use it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time